[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal nous sommes le
21 novembre 2016 voici le sommaire
françois françois fillon est la grande
surprise des résultats du premier tour
de la droite et du centre avec plus de
40 % dans le département les détails du
premier tour dans journal nous nous
rendrons à vélizy villacoublay où le
maire pascal thévenot présenté jeudi
dernier le nouvel aménagement prévu pour
la zac louvois son ambition pour
redonner un nouveau souffle au quartier
et puis clap de fin pour le festival du
film documentaire l'événement qui se
déroulait du 17 au 20 novembre à saint
quentin en yvelines a permis de
découvrir des films de la france entière
et même au delà le point sur le palmarès
on débute ce journal avec le résultat de
la primaire de la droite et du centre
est le premier constat c'est un succès
en terme de participation
bonsoir wilfried bonsoir haussmann
effectivement avant de regarder en
détail les résultats un mot sur cette
participation + 2 4 millions de votants
c'est presque deux fois plus que lors de
la primaire de la gauche en 2011 et
parmi ces votants plus de 250000 sont
yvelinois un succès et qui a amené
benoît hamon député socialiste a posté
d'ailleurs un commentaire sur twitter
exercice démocratique réussie aux
électeurs de gauche de jouer les 22 et
29 janvier fin de citation et puis
concernant les résultats à présent la
vague françois fillon at-elle submergé
le département alors regardez tout
d'abord à nouveau ces chiffres nationaux
on le rappelle françois fillon est plus
qu en tête 16 points d'avancé sur alain
juppé et puis vous le savez cette
élimination de l'ancien président et
nicolas sarkozy voici à présent les
résultats dans les yvelines françois
fillon est encore plus haut que la
moyenne nationale quasiment 49% elle
nicolas sarkozy qui lui s'effondre on
rappelle aussi tout de même qu'alain
juppé avait le plus grand nombre de
soutiens politiques dans ce département
on imagine le réveil difficile ce matin
pour tous ses soutiens devant cet écart
de près de 20 points avec
l'ancien premier ministre de nicolas
sarkozy écouter et karl olive c'est le
maire de poissy landais premier soutien
d'alain juppé dans le département et
c'est même lui qui avait ouvert le
dernier meeting au zénith et puis juste
après vous entendrez aussi une autre
réaction celle de bruno myle yens c'est
le président du modem dans le
département des yvelines une formation
est clairement engagée pour alain juppé
également le seul engagé en 2000 en 2013
avec alain juppé avant même qu'il est
annoncé sa candidature je suis un
compétiteur je n'attend pas la fin d'une
course pour annoncer lors des shows et
j'en suis fier et on va poursuivre cette
belle compétition car c'est une
compétition
ce n'est pas un combat et par rapport
aux résultats que vous avez pu découvrir
sur l'ensemble de l'hexagone où il ya un
raz-de-marée de françois fillon eh bien
on peut se satisfaire en tout cas qu
alain juppé ce soit il s'est malgré tout
en finale et qui sera un concurrent
projet contre projet pour la deuxième mi
temps si l'on peut dire dimanche 27
novembre je ne pense pas que le meilleur
candidat pour battre marine le pen
demain ce soit françois fillon c'est
plutôt alain juppé qui lui il réunira
plus de monde autour de lui si la gauche
est elle n'est pas en train de ceux en
train de se réunifier loin là on voit
bien les candidatures qui partent dans
tous les sens donc une forte probabilité
que la gauche ne soit pas présente au
second tour
il nous faut vraiment un candidat à la
fois rassembleur bourquin président de
tous les français
et qu'ils sont en capacité de battre
marine le pen
preuve d'une certaine fébrilité dans le
camp juppé néanmoins l'annulation du
meeting prévu ce soir en présence de
jean pierre raffarin à versailles une
autre réaction à présent ou plutôt
d'autres réactions celle des soutiens à
nicolas sarkozy tout d'abord celle de
david douillet le patron des
républicains dans les yvelines s'est
fortement impliquée dans cette campagne
il n'imagine d'ailleurs pas un retrait
complet de la politique de l'ancien
président et puis juste après la
réaction de flora sabbagh elle est
présidente elle aussi mais de la
formation des jeunes républicains dans
les yvelines il encourt douze ans
voilà qu'il soit en politique ou pas
peut-être que le fait de ne pas y être
lui prodiguera plus d'écouté et de
crédibilité vis-à-vis des des français
il avait le meilleur programme de cette
de cette primaire celui qui était le
plus lucide sur les toutes les
problématiques de la france et c'est
vraiment dommage que il était sanctionné
par
sarko bashing systématique
terminée dans la déception à l'effort il
ya un peu un sentiment d'inachevé à une
certaine amertume mais bon on ne
retiendra que merde cette campagne qui
était très bel enthousiasme et on a fait
plein de rencontres et c'est ça qu'on
retiendra essentiellement son bilan à
lui a coûté cher peut-être
oui enfin vous savez françois fillon
était le premier ministre de nicolas
sarkozy donc ils ont quand même un bilan
commun et voyez c'est un peu compliqué
de pouvoir juger uniquement sur sur le
vix nan parce que sa fille
dorénavant on doit pas perdre une minute
et tous
rejoindre françois fillon et s'aligner
derrière le candidat pour vraiment
incarné l'alternance forte dans notre
pays a besoin et puis à noter aussi la
réaction du président du conseil
départemental pierre bédier lui aussi
aux côtés de nicolas sarkozy qu'il
imaginait sans l'ombre d'un doute
l'emporté il s'est dit ce matin
totalement derrière françois fillon il a
tout mon soutien et toute ma confiance
la surprise est donc venue de françois
plus de françois fillon fasse attention
propre camp on n'imaginait pas une si
large victoire au premier tour exemple
avec suzanne blanc c'est la première
adjointe de montigny le bretonneux elle
est responsable du comité de soutien
local elle ne doutait pas un seul
instant de la présence de
françois fillon voilà elle ne doutait
pas de sa présence au second tour mais
pas avec un tel écart écoutez là
autant à un moment donné les gens le
voyait plus comme l'ancien premier
ministre
et petit à petit ils ont vraiment ils se
sont appropriés sont son programme et
ils ont presque oublié qu'il avait été
premier ministre non pas que ce soit une
tare loin s'en faut mais il n'avait plus
ce côté ancien premier ministre vraiment
le côté le candidat le candidat françois
fillon avec son programme c'était une
vraie belle surprise une vraie belle
surprise mais il faut savoir raison
garder et tant que le 2e tour n'est pas
fait voilà on ne crie pas victoire tout
de suite donc ça donne nicolas sarkozy
3e alain juppé deuxième françois fillon
premier et quelle place pour les autres
candidats une place parce anecdotique un
exemple avec bruno le maire présentait
comme le troisième homme en début de
campagne il s'est effondré et tout au
long des différentes semaine il est
cinquième au niveau national et même
sixième dans le département des yvelines
des yvelines voici l'analyse de philippe
benassaya c'est le maire de bois d'arcy
soutien de bruno le maire c'est un
effondrement soudain aux lions de mer et
fait figure un petit peu comment vivre
sans être désobligeant mais il fait
figure un petit peu de bonne élève voyez
donc mais ça ne suffit pas dans une
campagne électorale il faut aussi
séduire si des primaires ouvertes c'est
à dire qui est extrêmement compliquée
lorsque j'en suis pas fan je les écris
je les dis on je suis pas fan parce que
forcément vous fait rentrer des
stratégies politiciennes de gens qui ne
sont pas de droite forcément de gauche
d'extrême droite ou du centre
ne serait ce que des gens qui ne veulent
plus de sarkozy les gens qui veulent
plus de hollande des gens qui ne veulent
plus de personnes vont qui viennent
voter une primaire et lukaku ouvriers de
soutenir la corrida et pour terminer ce
tour d'horizon dans les yvelines tour
d'horizon des résultats ce dernier
tableau il concerne uniquement la 10e
circonscription c'est la circonscription
du député jean-frédéric poisson qui
était également candidat et il
enregistre son meilleur résultat au
niveau national il frôle l et 5% et il
atteint même les ronces % dans sa propre
commune de rambouillet jean frédéric
poisson qui devait venir ce soir en
plateau finalement il est resté sur
paris pour rencontrer les représentants
des deux finalistes car lui aussi il
entend bien négocié les quelques voix
qu'il a réussi à engranger pendant la
campagne eh bien merci à vous une frise
pour ses analyses
lifting pour la zac de louvois le maire
de vélizy pascal thévenot présenter le
nouvel aménagement prévu pour la zac de
loi jeudi dernier le but intégré à ce
quartier de nouveaux commerces de
nouveaux logements et des espaces verts
une première en france 2 hectares de
dalles démoli pour ramener au niveau du
sol tout un quartier c'est le pari fou
qu'a lancé le maire de vélizy
villacoublay pascal thévenot avec la
société sita dios le but donner à la
zone d'aménagement concerté louvois un
nouveau visage c'est un projet en fait
ambitieux puisque c'est la suppression
de vingt mille mètres carrés de dalle où
on va retrouver le sun naturel dans une
zone habitée puisque aujourd'hui vous
avez 260 logements qui sont sur la dalle
des locataires est donc le but c'était
de faire rentrer la forêt dans la ville
de retrouver le solde naturel de re
dynamisation commerciale qui était en
fin de vie puisque inaccessible et en
améliorant aussi un le confort des
nouveaux arrivants comme des locataires
actuels
la fin des travaux de la zac louvois est
prévue pour 2020 ça va permettre de
remettre aussi tous les services aux
pieds au pied des habitations plus
facilement accessible et au pied de la
station de tramway puisque sur ce
quartier aussi ce qui est extrêmement
important c'est que ce qui a été le
déclencheur du projet c est l arrivée du
tramway la création d'une station au
pied du quartier mais face à cette offre
de service aujourd'hui la station de
tramway les difficiles acc espa
difficilement accessibles donc grâce au
projet et grâce à la déconstruction de
la dalle on permet de recréer ces
liaisons beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
facilement le but aménager un nouveau
quartier et les travaux se feront en
quatre étapes
la société a tous france installé sur la
commune des clayes-sous-bois va
construire un centre de stockage
informatique et un nouveau super
calculateur pour financer ces deux
projets le département a débloqué 1,5
million d'euros un reportage de michael
et demi d'euros
cet officier le département des yvelines
a débloqué 1,5 million d'euros pour
financer la recherche et le
développement d'un nouveau
supercalculateur le bénéficiaire la
société à tous bull l'entreprise
implantée aux clayes-sous-bois va
pouvoir développer cette machine du
futur dans ses locaux
cette entreprise bull devenu atos est
une des perles du département
c'est un lieu
où s'exerce une compétition mondiale
particulièrement exacerbée et notre
travail d'élus c'est pas de faire de la
recherche à leur place c'est pas de leur
dire ce qu'ils doivent chercher bien
entendu on en est incapable c'est de
leur faciliter la vie pour qu'ils
puissent exercer leurs fonctions de
chercheur du mieux possible les
industriels ont besoin de soutien dans
leur dans leurs démarches en fait ça
crée un tissu disons de collaboration et
de partenariat qui nous permettent en
fait d'avancé la machine devrait être
capable d'effectuer un milliard de
milliards d'opérations simultanées une
première à elle permettra de stocker
calcul et analyser des masses de données
informatiques le projet sequana c'est un
projet majeur en fait dans notre axe de
recherche et développement nous
développons cette plateforme en fait qui
est un super calculateur qui s'inscrit
en fait daniel dans la lignée des supers
lac calculateur que nous avons déjà
développé ce programme va nous projeter
en fait dans l'oeuf une rupture dans les
prochaines vingt prochaines années en
parallèle le soutien du conseil
départemental permettra de financer un
nouveau data center un centre de
stockage de données dernière génération
sur le site historique du groupe atos
bull les premiers travaux sont prévus
pour l'année prochaine
clap de fin pour le festival du film
documentaire l'événement qui se
déroulait du 17 au 20 novembre à saint
quentin en yvelines a permis aux saint
quentinois de découvrir des films sur
teddy riner david douillet ou encore le
prof de gym de benoît grimont faisons un
point sur ces festivals
pendant 3 jours le festival saint
quentin à diffuser pas moins d'une
trentaine de documentaires un bilan
positif salué lors de la cérémonie de
clôture les films ont exploré le sport
sous tous ses aspects le dépassement de
soi l'émotion l'argent une plongée dans
un univers si ça sionnel il ya assez peu
de documentaires toute façon cinéma qui
sort au cinéma le sport
droit la mort c'était une bonne
sélection de qualité le prix des cinémas
a été remis au réalisateur benoît
grimont pour son film le prof de gym
dans un collège parisien sensible
l'histoire d'un prof de ps qui enseigne
à ses élèves médusé la danse
contemporaine pendant le cours de gym le
prof au lieu de faire du foot du
badminton je ne sais quoi ils essayent
et les seuils de transmettre et il
enseigne la danse contemporaine ont fait
la même chose on fait le même exercice
cela va me d sauf que c'est plus des
mots
et des petits mouvements
et l'appareil est connecté ça nécessite
la même concentration on voit la
transition et la transformation ces
gamins qui au début on n'avait rien à
faire et qui se retrouvent avec un petit
quelque chose dans le coeur une belle
leçon d'humilité donc qui ne manquera
pas de susciter des vocations
en attendant rendez vous est donné l'an
prochain pour une nouvelle édition du
festival saint quentin
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]